y'all seeing coco yeah yeah
but you just said you get me started we
tried justice movie i just saw it again
but i finished it for the first time no
you know the end is what you got wait
till the end that's when you cried yeah
i know i was on a flight that [ __ ]
landed right when the [ __ ]
couldn't go back to the
to the real world oh so i don't know
what happened okay don't ruin it for
people
i'm done that's nice
yesterday he's like yo who wrote coco we
need them to write our [ __ ] movie
a perfect building yeah guy's crying for
20 minutes
literally watching the [ __ ] crying like
knees over hands
you know what he's made as [ __ ] onward
can i say something thank you can i say
something can i say something [ __ ]
this is this is you watched onward yeah
not during the quarantine slash pandemic
okay onward came out if i'm not mistaken
when we were all quarantined yeah so we
got good when you got nothing better to
do yeah yes hater
nothing at all and then there's this
beautiful movie that comes out and
you're like beautiful dog that's just
beautiful
is good but it's like you said it was
the best move you ever saw you cried
three times not not not knocked three
yeah
no that's cap dude i did not cry few
times at coco i cried for the last 20
minutes straight it was like braveheart
for me but you didn't finish it i
finished it this last time oh okay and i
was bawling i can't believe you just
finished it so
everybody the way we've been talking
about that movie and you didn't finish
it before bro it was it was unbelievable
that guy turned out to be the bad guy
the whole time
no no you need to start seeing [ __ ] yeah
also you're not gonna you're not gonna
feel it the way we felt it yeah this
guy's got enough time to go on 15 dates
a week yeah he got no time to watch a
[ __ ] movie and then we can't talk
about beautiful movies and these girls
are probably 22 anyway they'd love to
watch it yeah if you watch that movie
with a girl you'll get married
i was weeping bro
it's beautiful who's going to put
anything on your friend hold on hold on
by the way you put it my date was
mexican
oh come on
and then my girl started watching in
kanto
that name be killing me i had no
interest they start the [ __ ] movie
i watched 10 minutes and i'm like i'm in
yeah i had to go yeah i just swim
but i was [ __ ] in dude
they are masters you know who wrote in
kanto though who lin-manuel miranda yeah
little uh here's the thing
in all due respect to
miranda like the dude has made some
bangers
he gives the initial then they give it
to the pixar people and they go we'll
take it from here moana banger
anything pixar no it's it's it slaps
everything right at which they hit yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
i watch every pixar a pixar movie that's
bad is one that you don't [ __ ] love
then you're like i was disappointed yeah
i didn't [ __ ] love it yes yeah if
it's not coco level you're like
oh holy [ __ ] the first ten minutes of up
toy story one two and three phenomenal
i didn't [ __ ] before but that's the same
thing i was like but still you're
squeezing all the juice out four yeah
yeah right andy 37.
it's a new family yeah what are we doing
guys
so this we need to get whoever's in
charge of pixar all right you know how
what's the one with the feelings oh it's
inside out i'm gonna watch that now i
haven't seen it oh my god this one's
gonna cry
i was built up so much for me that
disappointed me oh man but i also i'm
not i just be hating on you soul's fire
too you hate everything i like seoul
i like seoul so it was good it's always
good i thought what i liked about seoul
was i think we spoke about it was that
like um
it was a movie
or like it was a pixar whatever you call
them an animation like and i like i like
that pixar does this where it's like
oftentimes when you do a movie or
animation that has black people in it it
has to feel like this is a black thing
and one of the genius of like jordan
peele is like he's just making these
awesome horror movies that happen to be
filled with black people but they're not
this is a black movie
and i think
it's not pandering or it's not using
these like stereotypical characters
right it's just like hey these are the
people that this movie takes it and i'm
not pandering coco wasn't to me wasn't
like this is only for mexicans it was
like this just happens to take place
yeah yeah and and then that's what um
seoul felt like as well except seoul
most of the movie he's just a little
blue guy yeah that [ __ ] was it was
trippy that's a bait and switch you're a
black dude going to the theater like
finally a black movie and the whole time
it's just [ __ ] can i be honest i
thought soul was mid
really yeah i thought i thought it was a
little bit hype uh but it was good it
was good but that's again that's pixar
it's good so you're like i was
disappointed
fair enough
okay so here's my question the guy that
runs uh marvel dove what's his name
kevin feige kevin feige yeah ledge there
is a pixar version
of kevin feige
who the [ __ ] is that
lazader and then he kind of
went away now he's at a sun or skydance
animation but the same guys that are
this is what's interesting about pixar
the guys that are the animators from toy
story are still there as like the
executives so the executives are also
the creatives are also the directors
you're doing everything they're watching
over each other's projects so there's
like 50 collaborators on a project so
it's pete docter and andrew stanton i
mean just unbelievable
to be able to put something out
the the number of home runs they've hit
back to back to back to back to back is
insane like and let me just point out
this one thing if you are for example a
chef and you create the dish and you
make it every single time it's possible
for you to maintain that uh consistency
right then you start a restaurant you
can't be there every single day so you
gotta teach other chefs to do it but you
need to create enough like
systems and rules
so that they can make it consistently
like you and then you turn into
mcdonald's and you're like okay maybe
the quality's gonna go down but it's
gonna taste the same everywhere you go
right with these [ __ ] pixar movies
and movies just in general
there are
thousands of people working on this ship
right mm-hmm yeah like
to for have to have one guy in marvel
and one guy in uh pixar maintain more or
less the quality of every single thing
that comes out when you have to manage
thousands of [ __ ] people that's
impressive bro it's crazy and you know
what i what else i just realized pixar
hits at a higher percentage than marvel
yeah
facts whoa well it's not i'm gonna be
honest it's indisputable because i
didn't love inside out so many people
love inside out do you know anybody
whose favorite marvel movie is black
widow or scarlet witch or whatever the
[ __ ] no they have movies they put out
enough that you don't really notice but
they have movies that none of us really
give a [ __ ] about their avengers age of
ultron none of us loved it
that we don't even tune into them at all
like if you watch it you'll be like ah
like you'll snore through it
and these are these are things that come
out in theaters or these are yeah good
dinosaur was like fine cars cars sort of
sucked nah first people love cars people
drove cars that's that's the thing you
might not like it i didn't love inside
out people [ __ ] love it no it's just
for selling toys like cars planes all
that that was just for kid toys like
that kind of stuff good dinosaur wasn't
that good
uh luca was good
i thought
more for kids but you're gonna pixar's
business model hasn't changed they're
not making
uh as many things as marvel's gonna make
and marvel's about to make
ten times more like every single
character that you see in a feature is
gonna have a whole series is the eternal
slap i don't know a lot of people that
saw that that was good i thought people
keep playing watching it like that
he was good but it got slapped on and
seemed like it did fine
the the problem that marvel's gonna have
to uh figure out right now or the
solution for is that
the new
the new things that they're creating
right these new stories are based on
characters that we don't have any
nostalgia
with yeah right so like i don't know
what the eternals are now they're gonna
find out how powerful their brand is
yeah you know like it's like when a
clothing brand like puts out some
absolute dog [ __ ] and you're like ah but
it's gucci like now you find out how
powerful marvel is when you don't do a
wolverine when you don't do a
avengers when you don't do an x-men when
you do something like shang chi was a
character nobody [ __ ] heard of and
the fact that they made something good
you start going
okay maybe i should dabble in these
characters that i know nothing about
because they're so good at storytelling
yeah and yeah they did it with guardians
of the galaxy yeah that slapped that
slapped
and i i was walking in there like it's a
[ __ ] raccoon i'm gonna watch it
what's that director's name what's his
name
uh
james gunn
here's the thing i'll follow that
[ __ ] if james gunn wants to do
eternals i'll watch eternals if james
gunn wants to take some random character
we never [ __ ] heard of i'll watch
that so yeah kevin feige was that guy
but uh there's only one of him and what
happens at pixar is that there's like
20 of him and they stay at pixar they
work there full time to like be the
creative team and marvel is like you get
one kevin feige and then they assign it
to a new director and a couple new
executive producers each time you're not
gonna have that consistency that picks
our house
[Applause]